MONDAY AT 7:00.
GOOD NIGHT.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD
>> Tucker: WEOD
>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD
EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER KARL TONIGHT.
WE ARE NEARING THE END OF
OUR SECOND FULL WEEK OF
TOTAL SATURATION UKRAINE
COVERAGE.
THAT MEANS EVERY CHANNEL,
EVERY HOUR OF THE DAY.
SO AT THIS POINT YOU WOULD
THINK IT WOULD BE OBVIOUS
WHAT EXACTLY THE FUSS IS
ABOUT.
AFTER THIS MUCH TALKING, YOU
WOULD ASSUME EVERY PERSON IN
AMERICA WOULD UNDERSTAND
WHAT CRIMES DONALD TRUMP IS
BEING ACCUSED OF COMMITTING.
EVEN NOW THE STORY STILL
FEELS OBSCURE AND STRANGELY
LIGHT.
THERE IS NOTHING MYSTERIOUS
OR WEIGHTY ABOUT IT.
WE ALREADY KNOW ALL OF THE
FACTS.
THERE'S A TRANSCRIPT.
YET THEY STILL DON'T SEEM
VERY SHOCKING.
MAYBE FOR THAT REASON OUR
NEWS ANCHORS HAVE BEEN DOING
VERY BEST TO KEEP THE BLOOD
PRESSURE HIGH.
THE GAME IS BORING SO THE
CHEERLEADERS HAVE TO WORK
OVERTIME, TWICE AS HARD.
FOR EXAMPLE, HERE WAS
MSNBC'S BEST ATTEMPT TO GET
YOU TO CARE.
>> I DON'T SAY THIS LIGHTLY
BUT LET'S BE FRANK THE
NATIONAL NIGHTMARE IS UPON
US.
BASIC RULES OF DEMOCRACY
UNDER ATTACK FROM OUR
PRESIDENT.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH A
SERIES OF ADMISSIONS BY THE
PRESIDENT BUT ALL BUT
ASSURES IMPEACHMENT BY THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
NATIONAL EMERGENCY THE
FOUNDING FATHERS WOULD HAVE
CONSIDERED IT A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY THE PUBLIC
PUBLICLY LOBBIED FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS TO INTERFERE IN
THE NEXT ELECTION.
HARD TO SAY LIGHTLY BUT THIS
THE IS MOMENT THAT WE ARE
AT.
>> Tucker: I THINK A CLICHE
BOMB WENT OFF.
TRY TO FORGET HOW BAD HACK
KNEED.
THE STATE OF OUR NATION IS
IN RAPID DECLINE.
NOBODY CAN WRITE A DECENT
PARAGRAPH ANYMORE.
SOME DAY WE WILL DO A STORY
ON THAT.
THE BASIC RULES OF OUR
DEMOCRACY ARE UNDER ATTACK.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE TELLING
YOU.
SO WHAT EXACTLY ARE THE
BASIC RULES OF OUR
DEMOCRACY?
WELL, THE MOST BASIC RULE OF
ALL IS THAT THE PEOPLE RULE.
IN A DEMOCRACY, THE BIG
DECISIONS ARE MADE BY VOTERS
IN ELECTIONS.
THEY ARE NOT MADE BY LEFT
WING TALK SHOW HOSTS OR BY
"THE WASHINGTON POST" OR
EVEN BY HIGH LEVEL CIA
EMPLOYEES ACTING ANONYMOUSLY
AS WHISTLEBLOWERS.
NO.
IN A DEMOCRACY, THE MAIN
DECISIONS ARE MADE BY
CITIZENS CASTING BALLOTS.
THAT FOR EXAMPLE IS, HOW YOU
REMOVE A PRESIDENT.
BY BEATING HIM IN AN
ELECTION.
THAT'S ALWAYS THE WAY WE DID
IT HERE IN AMERICA.
NOT ANYMORE.
SO, YES, OUR DEMOCRACY IS
UNDER ATTACK.
THEY ARE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
AND, YET FOR ALL HIS FAULTS
DONALD TRUMP IS THOUGHT THE
ATTACKER.
BUT WAIT A SECOND THEY ARE
TELLING YOU.
WE UNDERSTAND HOW GRAVE A
DECISION IMPEACHMENT IS WE
ARE PRAYING OVER IT, PEOPLE
OF FAITH THAT WE'RE.
IN THIS CASE IMPEACHMENT IS
UNAVOIDABLE.
SOLICITING INFORMATION FROM
FOREIGN COUNTRIES IS CORRUPT
AND EVIL.
THESE WHAT THEY ARE TELLING
YOU OKAY.
FINE.
LET'S AT LEAST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THIS STANDARD IS A
BRAND NEW STANDARD.
I MEAN, BRAND NEW STANDARD
LIKE 20 MINUTES AGO BECAUSE
IT WASN'T THAT LONG AGO,
LESS THAN A YEAR.
YOU WILL REMEMBER THIS.
THAT ALL OF AMERICAN
POLITICS REVOLVED AROUND
INFORMATION SOLICITED FROM
FOREIGN COUNTRY, IT WAS
CALLED THE STEELE DOSSIER
BACK THEN THE PRESS CORPS
STRONGLY AGREED WITH IT.
>> THE ALLEGATIONS IN THEIR
STEELE DOSSIER AND YOU WENT
THROUGH THE TIMELINE A WHILE
AGO ARE STUNNING.
>> SUBSTANTIAL PORTIONS IN
THE STEELE DOSSIER A RAW
INTELLIGENCE DOCUMENT THAT
HAVE INDEED CHECKED OUT.
>> BASED ON OUR OWN
REPORTING AND WORD FROM
NUMEROUS OFFICIAL SOURCES
THE DOSSIER, IN FACT IS FAR
FROM BOGUS.
>> I THINK WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO ACTUALLY CALL IT THE
INFAMOUS DOSSIER.
INCREASINGLY IT'S THE
ACCURATE DOSSIER.
DAMNING DOSSIER.
INCREASINGLY THE DOSSIER
GOING TO HANG AROUND THE
NECK OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND DRAG THEM
DOWN.
>> Tucker: OH, THE DOSSIER.
TOTALLY FINE.
IN CASE YOU HAVE FORGOTTEN
AND YOU MAY HAVE FORGOTTEN
BECAUSE WHY WOULD YOU
REMEMBER BUT CHRISTOPHER
STEELE WHO WROTE THE DOSSIER
WAS A FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
OPERATIVE HE GATHERED HIS
MATERIAL ABROAD IN FOREIGN
COUNTRIES.
SOME OF IT CLEARLY FROM
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS.
AT THE TIME THAT WAS
ABSOLUTELY FINE WITH
DEMOCRATS.
THEY WEREN'T EMBARRASSED TO
SAY.
SO CLINTON CAMPAIGN STAFFER
BRIAN FALLON TWEETED THIS WE
COULD GIVE YOU A MILLION
EXAMPLES.
HERE IS HIS TWEET.
I DENY I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S HIRING
PREELECTION IF I HAD I WOULD
HAVE AGREED TO GO TO EUROPE
AND TRY TO HELP HIM.
OKAY.
AND BY THE WAY IF FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE IS SUCH A
CONCERN AND BY THE TWAY
SHOULD BE A CONCERN, THEN
WHY AREN'T WE MORE WORRIED
ABOUT FOREIGN COMPANIES
SENDING DE FACTO BRIBES TO
THE FAMILY MEMBERS OF
CONNECTED POLITICIANS?
THERE ARE A LOT OF THOSE.
WE ARE PICKING ON JOE
BIDEN'S SON BECAUSE HE IS IN
THE NEWS.
IT COULD BE A LOT OF
PEOPLE'S SONS.
TRUST ME.
S IN THE CASE OF BIDEN'S
SON, NOBODY THINKS IS HE
EXPERT ON UKRAINIAN ENERGY
POLICY.
HE GOT THE GIG BECAUSE OF
HIS DAD WHO WAS INFLUENCE
PEDDLING, OBVIOUSLY.
IN THIS CASE THAT'S OKAY
THOUGH FOR SOME REASON TO
BELIEVE.
BE TOTALLY HONEST.
LET'S STOP LYING IF WE CAN
FOR A SECOND.
I KNOW IT'S HARD IN AMERICA
WHERE EVERYONE IS REQUIRED
TO LIE ALL THE TIME.
IN WASHINGTON THERE ARE NO
ACTUAL RULES.
PARTISANS SIMPLY INVENT
STANDARDS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DESTROYING THEIR POLITICAL
ENEMIES.
JUST TODAY HILLARY CLINTON
TWEETED THIS FROM THE LATE
DEMOCRATIC MEMBER OF
CONGRESS.
THIS QUOTE IF THE
IMPEACHMENT PROVISION IN THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES WILL NOT REACH THE
OFFENSES CHARGESD HERE, THEN
PERHAPS THAT 18TH CENTURY
CONSTITUTION SHOULD BE
ABANDONED TO A 20TH CENTURY
PAPER SHREDDER.
BARBARA.
SHE THINKS WE OUGHT TO SCRAP
THE CONSTITUTION.
OH, PROBABLY NOT A QUESTION
THAT THAT CONCEPT APPEALS TO
MICHIGAN CONGRESSWOMAN
RASHIDA TLAIB THIS WEEK SHE
TOLD HER CONSTITUENTS THAT
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS NOW
CONSIDERING WAYS TO ARREST
MEMBERS OF TRUMP'S CABINET.
JAILING THEM IN DETROIT
WOULD BE A GOOD OPTION SHE
EXPLAINED.
WATCH THIS.
>> SO WE ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT, NO JOKE, WE ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WELL,
IS IT THE D.C. POLICE THAT
GOES AND GETS HIM?
NO, NO.
WHAT ARE WE HOPING?
SO I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW I
WILL RELAY YOUR MESSAGE.
I WILL TELL THEM THEY CAN
HOLD OFF PEOPLE HERE IN
DETROIT.
WE WILL TAKE CARE OF THEM
AND MAKE SURE THEY SHOW UP
TO THE COMMITTEE HEARING.
>> Tucker: JUST GOING TO
ARREST THEM.
THAT'S NOT THIRD WORLD OR
ANYTHING.
ARREST THE CABINET.
GIVE TLAIB CREDIT FOR
HONESTY.
SHE IS NOT PRETENDING TO BE
PRAYERFUL LIKE NANCY PELOSI.
SHE SAYS WHAT SHE THINKS.
AND SPEAKS FOR QUITE A FEW
PEOPLE IN HER PARTY.
WHAT YOU JUST WATCHED IN
THAT CLIP IS POLITICS ITSELF
BREAKING DOWN.
THAT'S NOT POLITICS, OF
COURSE.
THAT'S NOT PERSUADING PEOPLE
AND BRING THEM OVER TO YOUR
SIDE THROUGH REASON.
THAT'S SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
MODERN PARTISANS ON THE LEFT
DON'T WANT TO JUST WIN THE
NEXT ELECTION.
ELECTORAL POWER IS TOO TRAN
JENT.
IT HAPPENED BY THE WAY IN
2016.
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT TO TAKE
THAT RISK AGAIN.
SO THEY MOVED ON FROM THE
GOAL OF WINNING VOTES TO
UTTERLY DESTROYING THEIR
OPPONENTS.
THEIR ENEMIES.
THEY WANT THEM IMPRISONED.
THEY WANT THEIR FAMILIES
INTIMIDATED AND SUPPORTERS
INTIMIDATE AND DEMORALIZED.
VANQUISH RATHER THAN WIN
OVER.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD WAY TO RUN